foreign
foreign
foreign
the three Muslims first I want you guys
to let me know if if it's too dark let
me know and shall like and fix it make
it a little brighter man how you doing
today
all right you mind if I uh
fix it for a second guys
in like two weeks bro take all the time
in the world man it's not like we're
doing alive or nothing
[Laughter]
you know you funny guy huh
okay one second
better
all right
all right
what's going on guys today inshallah
we're going to be reacting to uh Vlad
and you again this was requested I think
starting a few streams ago and
throughout the last few streams so
inshallah we put together a little
Montage of their clips and uh the
perspective on Islam
and we will discuss that
Adam says I think that at the countdown
for stream delay to edit things like
video clips uh because they can't really
do it instantly
um I don't I think it's honestly the
reason just to bring more people in
before we start
um that's literally the only reason but
uh we got 237 viewers today
alhamdulillah send it to your friends
and like the stream inshallah will push
it out to more people
in China
that's my bro I actually never knew that
I thought we did the the countdown
because we're always late
but um that actually makes sense that
it's uh bringing people in so like once
we once it starts it's like we can
actually just start instead of waiting
yeah Insha'Allah
um
we have a um we actually have a super
chat from the guys themselves Vlad and
jugin we were lots of chat with you guys
sometime I honestly I was thinking if
they joined the stream if I see them in
the comments I'm gonna invite them on so
instead of going clubs we'll send you
the thing just DM me on Instagram at
Romy
I'll put on the screen in a second DM me
will send you the link you can hop on
and you guys can uh chat with us
inshallah
let me just put this up for you guys
and thank you for the Super Chat
all right Bismillah
subhanallah I was recently diagnosed
with diabetes I couldn't believe I don't
even weigh 140 I looked at it like why
is everything happening to me but
alhamdul brother if this is what Allah
has in store for me first they may Allah
bless you and have mercy on you make it
easy for you Allah I mean a variety of
people can get diabetes it doesn't mean
that you're fat
um I don't know much about it so I'm not
going to pretend that I do but I know
that you can anyone can get diabetes
it's had I think Angel knows and he
wants to say it
I was going to ask the question
uh is it type one type two which one is
it
let us know uh brother check yeah
Jesus is the Muslim says Allah is
Messenger said whoever says subhanallah
100 times a day will be forgiven all his
sins even if they were as much as the
form of the sea may Allah bless you
thank you for the Super Chat Allah
I mean I should probably be checking my
DM if I invited these guys
Bismillah
nothing yet nothing yet
but it's okay Insha'Allah
we'll give it some time
um Mr Yusuf asked uh Brothers can you
please put a Quran recitation along the
reminder uh rather than a plain boring
timer
yeah we want to we had uh brother yakia
who agreed to let us use one of his uh
his recitations but the thing with
YouTube is that they instantly flag if
there's a something that's reused so
even though he's giving us the the
permission to use it it's still going to
get flagged each time that we use it so
in order for us to actually put
something on there that doesn't get
flagged we would have to have
an original piece so inshallah one day
we will have an original piece yeah
we're working through the copyright
stuff um I think even if we do use his
thing he just has to not claim it
um and inshallah we should be fine but
uh we want to be absolutely sure before
we do anything
but we are working on that inshallah
super chat from my own brain says I was
an atheist for most of my life I
recently recently started believing in
God and Islam makes sense to me 90 of
the time but some things like the
Miracles or descriptions of Jannah are
hard for me to rap I'm assuming he means
rap his head around
um okay Insha'Allah you know first and
foremost that's amazing that most of
Islam makes sense to you and is you know
lines up with with what you already you
know what your own brain already
believes but
um what is the 10 that is hard to wrap
your head around is it something that is
a contradiction or something that
is just a little unbelievable to you I
think this will help us you know kind of
get to the bottom of it yeah
Sarah says if you believe in God then
Miracles should be easy to accept I
think 100 I mean we don't say Islam is
true because Moses split the sea we
don't say that we say we know Moses
split the sea because Islam is true and
the Quran says he's put the sea the
reason we believe Islam is true is
because of the evidence is in the Quran
uh the evidence of proof of prophethood
from the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him and I think those are just basically
the two biggest evidences that we have
foreign
it's weird to put a copyright on
recitation why limit your rewards Allah
it's not him it's not him
it's not him yeah it's just YouTube in
general it's uh
like when something is reused they just
completely they flag it real quick yeah
but even if um even if Yahya did decide
to do that
um I'm not a scholar but obviously
um as far as I know I don't even think
it's like it's not Haram like it's Halal
for him to do that
you know people have access to other
recitations for free online even them
they can listen to yahia's recitation
which shout out to brother
has amazing amazing recitation voice you
guys can go listen to it on his channel
yeah I think it's fine too bro because
if correct me if I'm wrong but
I do remember him using his recitations
like for his own YouTube videos and for
his business as well so it wouldn't make
sense that he he copyrights it if he
does copyrighted yeah 100 I honestly
think I don't know where he is
I don't know where he is I don't know
where he lives in some places as soon as
you make something and render it like
you basically own that thing
I don't know where he is on the rules
there but uh regardless
sister Nora asks how can I study the
Quran by picking it up and reading it if
you cannot read in in Arabic you can
read it in in English Insha'Allah but
make sure you're reading the tafsiris or
listening to a tafsir lecture like put
on a Newman Ali Khan video about
um you know Surah or something like that
his tafsiro not his tafsir about him
explaining from the other toughest year
in the past what they said about it
inshaallah that will help you get closer
to the Quran and understand it better
also get a teacher you know to practice
touchweed and all that I'm gonna give it
one more chance if Brothers Vlad and
yugen
sent a request
I inshallah will invite them on
but it doesn't look like they have so
inshaallah let's just begin with the
reaction what do you say oh no
let's go bro
all right I'm just gonna pull it up here
check texts
okay type I'll do that in just one
second let me pull up this
Montage so recently Andrew Tate has
converted to Islam and because of that
we're gonna be looking at 10 surprising
facts about Islam you know what do you
know anything about Islam before we
start I'll be real all I know is that
there's the Quran and that there's a lot
of strict things in the Quran like a lot
of things that you cannot and can't do
because all I hear is people on social
media going Haram you lifted a pencil up
the wrong way Haram like that's that's
all I hear nowadays yeah I mean I'm
familiar with the term Haram but I know
literally nothing else no I don't know
anything else Islam is often referred to
as a Deen which comes from the Arabic
word for way of life Muslims believe
that Islam is more than just a religious
belief but it's a way of living in
accordance with one's religious faith it
makes sense because if you look at the
Quran although I don't know the
specifics about it as I said earlier
there's a lot of there's a lot of rules
and there's a lot of things that you can
and can't do complicated to get into it
sounds sounds hard is what it sounds
like but yeah you know what it is it's
like people always say like I've watched
a few debates between Christians and
Muslims and other religions and it's
like for me it's very difficult to pick
any sides because how do you know like
how do you know any side you know I mean
like you know it's it kind of feels hard
sometimes you're like you see all this
and you're like who's to believe you
know I mean there's so many books like
How long is that yeah because the Bible
is like 3 000 pages and if you think me
and Vlad are reading that [ __ ] you have
another thing coming man yeah man the
quran's probably similar if not longer
so like there's just so much to know
yeah so you just like watch videos like
these yeah and whichever one convinces
you yeah yeah exactly you gotta watch
the debate be like like you know what
that does that seems right yeah that
seems right I'm gonna do that if all all
right so we're already off to uh to a
great start here
on Hill what's the first thing
especially towards the end that stood
out to you
uh yeah you don't you don't find the
truth by looking at just random videos
like that or even the big videos or
something like this
you know am I am I hate you off to like
something but you gotta look for the
answers yourself
yeah 100 and I'm going to the source is
always the best thing to do because I
mean you'll hear and I'm not we're not
saying that going online inherently is
bad it's just you open yourself up to a
lot of half-truths misconceptions and
especially when it comes to Islam online
unfortunately there's a lot of people
out there who are obviously not Muslim
that give the half truths in the outer
context and try and make it sound look
bad so you got to go to the source
yourself something that stood out to me
was
he said the Bible's like 3 000 pages and
the Quran is probably the same if not
longer I looked at this today
my Quran including the indexes and like
those extra pages and extra uh authors
notes and all that is under 400 Pages
under 400.
I I believe there are books novels out
there that are longer than the Quran
very short very sweet and very beautiful
also when it comes to deciding which
religion is true it's not as difficult
as people think because they think all
of a sudden when you deal with religion
you're dealing with another realm it's
not like when you go and you decide oh
is the earth flat or is it round let me
look at that evidence
it's it's not different from that you
know it's not like now you're in a
different realm because you're dealing
with spiritual things no if a religion
is true the claims that the the book
gives or that the religion gives
will be accurate the Miracles that it
provides will be miraculous and it will
not be basically contended with anything
and when you really kind of get down to
it you find there is no Contender
Contender for Islam there is nothing
similar to the Quran and I watch your
videos I really do appreciate them and I
think one thing you guys could concede
to is the fact that there is nothing
similar to the Quran with all the facts
that were given all the accuracies all
the things that were mentioned that the
prophet peace be upon him at that time
could not have known
all those things hint towards the fact
that this is greater than just you know
a man or a civilization coming together
to produce a book
so I think you guys can see that there's
nothing like the Quran and nothing like
Islam
bro do you have anything to add yeah
they said it seems difficult it seems
like there's a lot that you have to do
but
Slim's easy bro
yeah just a misunderstanding
100 he gave I don't know if I included
it but he gave an example like you know
oh you picked up the pencil the wrong
way Haram and it's like exactly like you
said it's a misconception yeah yeah yeah
that's there's people trying to make a
joke out of it yeah yeah
um and I get it you know he has to be
entertaining through in the video and
stuff but um like Islam really in terms
of actions boils down to a few things
two of them are General I'm going to
expound upon those inshallah pray five
times a day
fast the month of Ramadan give two and a
half percent of your not your income of
your savings your extra wealth your
excessive wealth two and a half percent
of that towards charity
um and go for what we call Hajj once in
your life which is a pilgrimage to matka
if you are able to do so if you're
physically and financially able to do
that
so those are the four things that you
are obligated to do now there are other
things that are on top for example you
know it's obligatory for Muslims to seek
knowledge to learn Islam so as long as
you're over time learning Islam you're
fulfilling the obligation uh so we're
maybe at five things now and then
obviously we have the enjoining good and
forbidding evil what is that in joining
good is calling for goodness right
calling other people to come and pray
calling other people to do good and
doing good yourself the extra good deeds
that people like to do giving extra
charity and so on and so forth extra
prayers and all that and then forbidding
the evil which means you hold yourself
from doing evil and others from doing
evil now let me ask you guys something I
want to ask you guys a question
if you guys were given a list of things
that were detrimental either to you or
to society as a whole
would you not look at that as a list of
things you should not do in life
I think most people will look at that
list of detrimental things that are bad
for you in society and would say these
are the things I'm going to avoid that
is what Haram is it's not just like oh I
don't like that you did this this way
and not that way
it's this is what is best for you these
are the things that are worse for you
and Allah says in the Quran you may love
something which is bad for you
and you might hate something while it's
good for you you don't know and Allah
knows so that is why our Lord our
creator the old knowledgeable the
all-wise the only one who knows
everything well we know very very very
little and the little we know was only
given from Allah that's why Allah our
creator has the right alone the only one
with the right to make legislation and
rules in a way of life for us as human
beings
why don't you give them the uh the Ikea
analogy I really like that one
yeah it's like when you get something
that Ikea like this you get a bed frame
comes with an instruction manual
would you
if you had this instruction manual would
you throw away the manual and then try
to just build the bed frame by yourself
probably not
you couldn't
might take you a really long time to
figure out or you might not figure it
out at all
you know and that's that's kind of like
life
you know uh the Quran is the instruction
manual for life
and you can you can choose not to use it
you can choose not to even uh put taking
it and you could say no I'm gonna figure
it out myself this with a lot of uh
spiritual people like to say they like
to make the argument like oh I want the
freedom to figure it out myself
but it's like why like you're gonna be
here you're gonna like this is the
straight path you're gonna be on it for
like a second and then you're gonna go
off somewhere else then you're gonna
come back for like a second and you're
gonna go out somewhere else and it's
like I said the instruction manual if
you don't have it you might never
actually build the bed frame it might
never actually be complete so imagine
dying never actually knowing all the
answers never actually knowing the truth
never actually staying on the correct
path imagine you die while you're off
over here and uh God knows where
you know so it's it's better to use the
thing that our creator has given us
to actually maneuver
and navigate through life
100 absolutely absolutely and the reason
I like that analogy so much is because I
put together Ikea products and it sucks
bro it is difficult without bro without
the manual I wouldn't be able to do it
like I put together three like freaking
stand-up dressers for my wife without
the manual bro it's honestly I would not
have done it but now imagine something
as complex as life where you're dealing
with things where there's no there's no
axiomatic principle for example morality
there is no Baseline principle that
everyone believes in and agrees on and
can you know not prove because they
don't prove axioms that is just
universally accepted right like the pain
and harm principle is not something and
there are different even variations and
understandings of that it's not
something that is completely understood
and accepted by people so the base
morality off of it well not everybody
agrees on that so imagine now trying to
find moral truths uh as you know on top
of the world of the secular studies like
scientific truth and so on and so forth
historical truths trying to find moral
truths what is you know which actions
are best
you have no way of you know concretely
determining these things we don't know
as human beings I'm sorry we kind of
suck we're not able to determine those
things and yes we are all for human
advancement and so on and so forth but
we need to understand our limitations
or else we're going to think we're not
limited and then we can start making
legislation and then we find our
legislation slots it slaps us back in
the face we find that our way of life
ends up slapping us back in the face
like liberalism
so we want to avoid that concede to okay
we don't know who knows only Allah
and Allah says
this is beautiful
and I said because someone corrected me
by time and this time is time that's
running out
he says Allah says indeed he swears by
time that's running out indeed mankind
is in loss mankind as a whole during
loss
and those who exalt each other to
the truth and exalt each other towards
being patient
this summarizes our whole existence in
our life
if you need to watch it back and listen
to that again I suggest that you do
inshallah
what do you say we get back to the video
now
Bismillah
where is it all qurans in the world
today were destroyed the original Arabic
would still remain this is because
millions of Muslims called Hafiz or
guardians or memorizers depending on the
context have actually memorized the
Quran letter by letter word for word
from the beginning all the way to the
end how is that even possible bro dude
is literally reading to us who don't
understand anything that to me like that
squiggles obviously it's a language but
that's sweet dude is reading a 5 000
page book of that and knows every word
you know what this looks like to me like
remembering all of this is like you know
that one guy who has a crazy memory they
took him on the helicopter and he like
redrew New York City or some [ __ ] oh
yeah that's yeah that that's the type of
like level of memorization right there
they just get like the high functioning
autistic mathematicians just to like
infinite memory yeah
this is the mathematical Miracle of the
Quran so you know I can see every pixel
on the screen right now but let's get
right into it punishment in the Holy
Quran throughout the whole Quran it is
repeated some 117 times whereas the
words forgive is repeated some 234 times
which is exactly half of 234 that's a
mathematical mirror this number 117 is
exactly half of 234.
I didn't even notice that yeah so the
word forgive is double punishment so
they're trying to push more of
forgiveness than punishment interesting
let's see what he says about it
on that note there's actually a verse in
the Quran where I forget the verse so
someone please put it if you know what
it is or Allah he mentions basically
you're allowed to retaliate in in an
equal amount to whatever harm was done
to you
and then he says but forgiveness is
better
so that was what came to my mind when I
saw this subhanallah
234 if you multiply 117 by 2 you're
going to have 234. it is very meaningful
why because quranic morality Allah
recommends Allah orders Believers Allah
orders Muslim Muslims to forgive rather
than punishing it is very meaningful
yeah man just forgive most of the time
but then you know that 117 times some
things cannot be forgiven sometimes you
gotta punish him man Allah orders to our
Prophet say it is repeated some 332
times and the response they said it is
again equally repeated some 330. okay
that's that's actually crazy that that
actually is crazy because oh my gosh
because you'd have to perfectly
orchestrate where the words go and like
oh my God literally mathematically
correct the words World hand and
Hereafter there are repeated 115 times
equally devil and angel those two words
are equally repeated some 88 times now
Heaven and Hell those two words are
equally repeated seven or seven times
zika zika is an Arabic word its
translation is donation the financial
donation that Muslim is supposed to give
to Poor's and it distributed 32 times
and the Barrack had the blessing that
comes out of giving a donation to a poor
it is repeated 32 times in the whole all
of these things you know what I'm gonna
have to who noticed who's the one who
was like hold on a second here are they
saying this the same amount of times
like who was the one because in the
Islam religion as far as I'm aware of
the book was created by Allah and or God
and given to Muhammad a prophet who was
illiterate and didn't understand what he
was given but throughout decades and
centuries of time we have come to
understand the Quran more than we did
before and over time they just noticed
that heaven and hell were said 77 times
each like who would even like who who
would realize that I don't know but I'm
gonna have to go back and just just
count him real quick because that is
actually just go your local mosque be
like hey can I get one just one two
three four five six like that'd be crazy
like uh one's off oh one off one's off
on that on that note firstly uh I wanna
blow their minds even more they don't
like they don't understand I want to
blow their minds even more the Quran was
written down or not written down let me
let me get to the first part the Quran
was revealed to the prophet peace be
upon him and the prophet revealed to the
people over the span of 23 years over
the span of 23 years without going back
and saying oh no I said that law I said
that wrong let me redo it let me oh this
this verse here with this word let's
switch it to that word without any of
that was revealed over 23 years
piecemeal meaning like off the top from
the human's perspective the process that
was revealing this kind of like
Freestyle over 23 years so to have a
book with all throughout the book all
these beautiful you know
um mathematical Miracles or whatever
they call them over 23 years
that is much more astonishing because he
couldn't read it right he wasn't sitting
you know writing it down or anything
like that
so that was
you know phenomenal subhanallah
and there was another point they made
towards the end of kind of forgetting it
now but uh they were saying that like
who counted this oh they gotta
understand like there were people that
study the Quran yeah and they study
someone asked in the beginning how do I
study the Quran like people who give
these tough seers these Scholars who
give these tough cities like they've
studied it in depth so they would know
this if it has so-and-so words repeated
so and so times
yeah 100 and also nowadays we have like
engines and stuff people put the Quran
into an engine and they find how many
times they're in words were said yeah
bro and his was even more crazy here's
what really blows the mind because they
were talking about the prophet Muhammad
that he was literally couldn't read or
write
yeah and he was he received everything
through
uh the Angels agree right so it was a
oration he was repeating it orally oily
now what blows the mind even more is
that like
how is he gonna be like oh you know this
word
um 20 times here and 40 times over there
but he didn't think about this he didn't
do that that was all a law that created
that as like a miracle and then it goes
even deeper it's not just like the
numbers but it's also the ring
composition
and if they don't even know about that
listen go on YouTube and Just put that
in and just just you see for yourself
man it's
it truly is a miracle when you actually
get down to it
yeah 100 percent
and what's even like just like the
cherry on top of all of that is a lot in
the Quran he actually challenges people
right he says listen if you just believe
in this book bring just one chapter like
it just one chapter
the shortest Surah in the Quran
it has I believe ten words or so three
verses only three verses long ten words
or so and uses over 20 literary and
rhetorical devices including prophecy
and and obviously rhyming and so on and
so forth
and there there's actually a website
that talks about this in other videos
that you know dissect it imagine making
off the top of your head
a 10 word three verse chapter
that has 12 over 20 literary and
rhetorical devices
and Allah challenges people he
challenges listen you see all these
beautiful linguistic and and so on and
so forth miracles in the Quran bring
just one chapter like it 1400 Years bro
1400 years nobody has done a thing
there's one person who tried it was um
that was probably many people tried but
one I know of is Professor Krause who's
a who's a physicist he took a bunch of
Arabic words and put them in like some
like machine some some
um program he created
and two of the verses that it spat out
ended up being quranic verses but the
challenge is not to produce the quranic
verse is to produce that like it so he
still failed to do that people have
tried but 1400 years uh they have failed
talking about Lawrence Cross yeah yeah
the guy you really did that and he was
trying to claim that he produced
something like it yeah it's in the
debate with thumbs up
bro
it was a really really interesting
debate
I think we reacted to it actually like a
year ago or so no I don't think and we
did we just reacted like a few points
because I remember that yeah yeah
all right let's get back to the video
inshallah fully repeat it it is very
meaningful again or just in the extra
credits just write help
gotcha now summer hot and winter cold
those words are equally repeated five
times and richness and poverty those two
words it is very interesting Rich
richness is repeated 26 times whereas
the poverty is half of 26 which is 13
and woman and man those are repeated
equally 23 times well do you know any
idea what those numbers represents well
let me remind you what do you think they
represent equality well not all of them
are equality well like the man and woman
the ones that are equality okay so the
ones that are equally represent equality
well there's equal force of Good and
Evil okay what about riches and poverty
why are they different and what does
that represent
um maybe with um what was that previous
one good and evil or something like that
and one was double there was punishment
and uh right forgiveness maybe it's like
richness as in not actual materialistic
richness but like Rich of the Mind
almost and poverty may be the opposite
of that I was thinking more of the term
that rich people just have more and poor
people have less that's what I was
thinking I mean yeah that works too I
guess it's just the way you look at it
honestly you remember from the
chromosome numbers of a human being from
the previous slides a human body
contains 46
I'm going to be completely honest I
meant to cut like all this out because
it was just like a lot of just facts and
all that stuff
um but since we're here 23 chromosomes
sorry this there's 46 chromosomes
together to make up like a human being
23 come from the mother 23 come from the
father
um and that's why there's significance
in that that's what the brother points
out but without being said I'm just
going to skip to this part inshallah
we'll read it out yo this this really
makes me want to go play Minecraft right
now man let's go I'm making fun of the
video quality whereas the word c
repeated 32 times well that first sight
doesn't seem to be very meaningful
however if you do a simple math you're
gonna have 30 if you add 32 you're gonna
have 45 as for the result and
the percentages if you divide 13 to 45
you're gonna have 28 comma eight eight
percent and 32 to 45 as for the word c
you're going to have 71 comma 1 1
percent now do you have any idea what
those percentages represent well I'll
tell you those numbers will give you the
all the lands all over the world wow so
71 of land is water 28 of land is land
oh my God who did this what the heck who
did this they counted land and sea and
then divided them and then basically
they said okay 71 of the world is water
and 28 is land what we're gonna do is
we're gonna get a number we're gonna
save both of those words 45 times but 28
of the time it's going to be land so 13
times and the other percent is going to
be 32 times this is like Eminem if he
was playing 4D chess what kind of what
kind of riddle lyrical Miracles that's
going on right now the Holy Quran is
word of Allah and it cannot be
definitely can't be a scripture of a man
this is not possible so okay well I mean
it could but if it happened if the book
was given 2000 years ago then no it
couldn't but the thing is is that I mean
could the book is the book updated is
the Quran updated or is it just left the
way it was is it untouched if it's
untouched then I don't I just don't how
do you explain that there is no
explanation well maybe we'll have to
watch some people try to explain it
watch some people and they can explain
it because I I don't know all right guys
it is untouched Habibi
absolutely it is untouched
that's the miracle of it
yeah and um adding on to that Allah says
in the Quran that we have we have you
know revealed the Quran we have sent
down the Revelation sorry am I Frozen
Can you guys see me no no you're good
bro go ahead okay I froze on my own
screens
basically we have sent down a reminder
and we will preserve it Allah actually
promises the Quran will be preserved now
let's look at like for example you guys
mentioned the Bible a lot let's look at
the Quran compared to the Bible every
single New Testament scholar on the face
of the Earth says the Bible has changed
there's not one New Testament scholar as
far as I know at least on the face of
the Earth that in this day and age
claims the Bible has never been altered
or changed and it's because when they go
back and look at the abundance of
manuscripts they found from earlier
manuscripts to later ones
there have been things added to it when
you look at the Quran and you look at
the manuscripts the manuscripts which we
have an abundance of those as well
and how even the scholars and the
companions of the Prophet peace be upon
him were quoting the Quran and
explaining it even their quotes of the
Quran not mentioning verses in their
narrations and so on and so forth is
exactly the same as what we have in the
Quran today there are obviously some
Scrabble like small Scrabble mistakes
and so on and so forth but when you look
at the abundance of manuscripts you find
that they all align with the Quran we
have today furthermore
I want to mention
even people like you know Bart Ehrman
barterman's not an Arabic scholar he's
not a quranic scholar
um he's a new testament scholar and
historian but even he you know in his
expertise uh knows and has admitted that
the Quran and the tradition of
preservation the Muslims had seems to be
very authentic like that of the Jews
like they took care of their scripture
basically
so
you know there's an abundance of
evidence you just have to really just
have to look
yeah it's um
Allah says many times like the signs are
everywhere
the signs are everywhere and y'all are
over here watching these videos on like
the Miracles of the Quran the mathematic
not the mathematic but the uh the
numerology of it is that correct to say
the numerology or is it some is it a
different term
numerology of of what like just the the
numbers like always like this is a nice
idea like well what would this term be
called
I have no idea let's just I guess for
simplicities they call it like
mathematical Miracles or whatever
colors colors so you got these you got
these things that you're reacting to you
keep going you got linguistic Miracles
you got the ring composition you got
these things that were revealed to a man
like over 1400 years ago
couldn't read it right
how could this man know the distance in
the Earth how much was land and how much
was water
how could he know at one point in the
Quran
Allah says not not the prophet Muhammad
peace and blessing to be upon Him Allah
says because everything in the Quran is
Allah
all right now Allah says in the Quran
that that the clouds that he holds the
clouds up that they're heavy these heavy
clouds are holding up now listen back
then there was no way that anyone could
have known that clouds were heavy I mean
even us today if no one were to ever
tell you that that an actual Cloud
weighs a ton or maybe even more than a
ton
you would think to yourself ah it's like
Vapor or something like this it doesn't
really weigh much right
but a cloud literally weighs like a ton
and that's like a small Cloud now
imagine a huge
I was about to say bad way but imagine a
huge Cloud bro imagine how many tons
that is and it's it's just floating in
the sky it's literally floating in the
sky
and this was said by Allah 1400 years
ago
in this book that has not been changed
and then it talks about so many of the
things like the uh the embryo like the
the stages of the embryo as it goes
through the um the 10 months a woman's
pregnant for 10 months right I believe
nine is the average nine okay nine and
ten nine and ten Eleanor's best right
but it says the stages of the embryo and
it Compares it to that of a leech how
bro how would someone know this back
then
and it doesn't stop there like it keeps
going it keeps going keeps going so
again it's like Allah says like the
signs are everywhere
100 yes I mean Allah he says you know
the signs are there for those who who
you know are willing to reflect you know
so if you're not willing to reflect and
really say and be in awe of you know the
most merciful and so on and so forth
yeah if your heart's closed off as a
person you're not you don't care for
these things okay then whatever you know
you're gonna live your life and screw
off and whatever and you're gonna wake
up on a on a vast day on a very
difficult day on the day of judgment and
you're gonna have to be held accountable
for whatever you said and did and you
know you would have had the signs but
you just neglected them and you know
yeah at the end of the day that is only
your fault as a person
um but all like this whole thing
Allah beautifully summarizes with the
Ayah I mentioned before where he says
just bring one chapter like it if I
think to to make this whole argument
simple if this is something that a human
being could do then another human being
would have done it you had great
playwrights like Shakespeare and other
great playwrights in his time Eminem's a
great rapper you have other great
rappers in his time there is nothing
even similar Habibi nothing even similar
to the Quran the very fact that the only
person who did it is saying he only got
it from Allah got it from God
and nobody else on the Facebook could do
it is evidence in and of itself that it
must be from God obviously you're going
to be people like oh you're you know
they're making a logical Gap fallacy
okay I'm not trying to be super logical
I'm trying to be rational what makes the
most sense here
data comes from Allah
let's inshallah again bro 100 I mean at
this point If you deny it Annie give us
your evidence for your reasoning for
denying it not Vlad and yugen I think
they're good guys that think they're
sensible men uh but anyone who denies it
bring your you know your reasoning
inshallah
how's it going today we're going to be
reacting to why the Quran is a miracle
we've gotten a bunch of comments asking
for it so now it's here what do you
think why is it a miracle bro from what
we've reacted to everything in there is
a miracle from the way the words were
placed and how it predicted everything
or not predicted I guess new everything
I don't know everything we're seeing so
far is a miracle so I don't know what
this show was yeah it's pretty so pretty
ridiculous in Islam faith is not blind
it is based off knowledge oh I know this
video bro when Muslims are asked why you
know bro I saw this I saw this video
first on your Instagram when I first
became Muslim and then you and I started
talking I remember I looked on your
Instagram and you had the link in your
bio and I watched that I was like
subhanallah
this is amazing yes panel this this was
this video was made by Riyadh yeah I
could tell the voice the voice I
remember he messaged me and he was like
Hey you know let me know what you think
and I watched I was like bro the editing
in this and I want you guys to pay
attention to that thing Allah it's
absolutely beautiful yeah yeah why they
believe Islam is the truth they respond
by saying the Quran is the proof but
when they are asked to explain how it
can be difficult to give a satisfying
answer because there is just so much
that can be said so
how is the Quran a miracle Allah
revealed the verse in the Quran
affirming that he would protect his
Revelation from ever being corrupted
1400 years ago so he's saying that it
can never be corrupt the meaning that it
can never be changed kind of like the
Bible like the Bible goes oh well you
know gay people want to get married now
so I guess we'll take that part out of
the book yeah but I guess the Quran
didn't change anything if you think
about it this is a huge claim to make
yet we find the Quran remains completely
unchanged after all these years
no matter where you are in the world the
Quran is one and no two Muslims disagree
in another verse Allah says that he has
made the Quran easy to learn and asks if
there will be anyone that will learn it
every single generation since the Quran
was revealed has had memorizes making it
the only book to have passed down in
human memory considering most Muslims
don't understand the language the speed
at which they can learn the Quran is
almost unbelievable
to give you an idea imagine memorizing a
page of Chinese in a matter of half an
hour no I can't imagine bro wait so they
memorize it without knowing how to read
that's what he just said in it yeah
people said people of the Comets have
said there's two-year-olds who know the
whole Quran and I'm sitting there like
brev like when I was two bro I couldn't
even walk I don't think like I don't
know what's going on bro I can't even
remember anything for tests in school
yeah I mean we talked about this the
other day but we like basically I said
that if I went back to grade 12 and
redid all my finals I wouldn't pass a
single class guaranteed yeah I don't
have like memory of anything that I've
learned is that like do you do you guys
relate to that are we just idiots or do
you guys like not remember basically any
of the stuff in high school because
there are more than 100 million
memorizers of all its 600 Pages word for
word letter for letter you might be
asking why is the Quran in Arabic if
most Muslims on Arab well Allah tells us
why in many verses in one he says to
remove any crookedness or confusion and
in another so that it may be perfectly
clip we now know that Arabic is one of
the most eloquent languages that
delivers incredible depth and precision
with the least amount of words in Arabic
one single word can translate into a
full descriptive sentence
if the Quran was in English it would
have to be thousands of pages thicker if
not more just to carry a close enough
meaning the effect that the Quran has on
those who listen to it being recited can
easily be seen from the thousands of
reaction videos on YouTube wait so
they're saying that if we we watch a
video about the whole Quran me and you
are going to be bawling our eyes out I
don't think I'll be crying bro I don't
think I'd cry maybe a law would make me
cry like oh you think you strong boy
Pride let me show you something it
literally brings people to tears despite
them not understanding the language what
star who is this white boy crying about
bro wait Arabic so not only are they
crying
so like imagine speak some Ukrainian
right now
like how does that work is that true I
don't know they say it's a reaction
video we gotta react to this reaction
videos yo try not to cry challenge Quran
edition let's try that Challenge and
it's just nothing that we understand a
lot
well firstly
try it
try it put on a Quran recitation and I
think Riyadh when he said that he didn't
mean that they don't know what's being
said they have the translation but they
don't understand what the Arabic words
mean word for word and let me tell you
as someone who didn't speak Arabic
um and I still don't speak Arabic
fluently both the words that I have
learned when I hear the Quran recited
and I know what the words mean and I
hear those words being recited it
impacts me more than just reading a
translation so that's what he's
referring to but try it put on the
quranifestation do a reaction and you
don't need to cry not everybody is going
to cry but the fact that there are
significant amount of people that do cry
when first listening to the Quran while
reading the translation and knowing what
it means obviously they do cry is a huge
evidence because Allah says that he
predicts that basically there will be
people or he knows obviously he tells us
there will be people who have soft
hearts and they cry when they recite or
read or hear the Quran I know you can
relate to this man I've cried so many
times listen to the Quran yeah man
before Islam if I would have heard
someone speaking like this I'd be like
bro you were soft as hell man but man it
really is something beautiful
you know and
even if you're not even if you don't
even have the translation even if you're
not like understanding anything that's
being said it's just something different
like the energy that hits you when the
Quran is being recited and Allah says
like beautify the words beautify his
words and when you are reciting you have
these people who are reciting in such a
melodious and beautiful way and it's
like just imagine this right
we as humans were very limited in many
of the things that we can do now as
humans we are reciting you have certain
people who Allah has gifted with
beautiful masha'allah beautiful voices
right these people are reciting the
Quran with an amazing voice melodious
that can move you to tears like it
literally has energy and when you hear
it in person completely different
if that's us listening to another human
being
imagine the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him receiving it from the Angels
you believe
oh my God if we're crying imagine this
man imagine this man who
supposedly
it said that he's sinless yet every
single day he was asking Allah for
forgiveness
if someone is doing this like you know
they have to know in the heart that what
they're saying is 100 the truth
so it's again like how can you deny
Islam
100 100
I inshallah these guys seem very sincere
I think that inshallah in time and
reflecting on the things that you'd
mentioned and listen to the Quran and
reading it I think they will come to see
that Islam is the truth and that Islam
is the solution for Life once they start
to get into it they'll see Islam as a
solution for any problem that a person
could have because mainly because at its
like very basic level practices it
prevents issues from arising like the
whole problem of STDs would not be a
thing
if we lived in Islamic Society it would
not be a thing especially with how those
things were formed
um
Islam would not allow such a thing
we have a super chat from um
uh the same brother from before I'm
seeking the truth and uh and be the best
person I can I will get a list of my
questions I'm on the edge of becoming
Muslim but I don't want to have
um half about it I want to submit fully
in mind soul and heart inshallah
inshallah bro let us know when you're
ready you can come on we're gonna later
today inshallah actually so one day you
can join us yo question did the
subscriber that was talking about the
diabetes did you ever get back did he
ever say yes type one or type two I
didn't see it personally but it's
possible that I missed it because we
have a lot of people in here right now
oh man I wanted to I wanted to speak
about that yeah yeah it's okay inshallah
you can you still can but I want to read
this quickly STDs and superbugs were
prophesied as well
yes the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said in an authentic
Hadith that anybody could read if they
just look it up he said that basically
the end of time or the last day will not
come
until
promiscuity sexual promiscuity and and
uh you know basically fornication is so
widespread that people start doing it in
the streets like donkeys that's how he
described it
right and he says and the spread of
diseases that people have never seen
before
would spread wide
so we have those two things
disgusting
bro
my boy in Thailand was telling me that
he's seeing people doing it on the
street bro
again something Islam will not allow
because if you have four male Witnesses
see that happen
it's not going to be a good day for you
if you're married it's really not going
to be a good day for you if you're
cheating on your spouse really going to
be a bad day so Islam does not allow
such you know disgusting things to
happen alhamdulillah
let's bring the the Brotherhood from the
the
brother that wants to do this child I
can't even speak it's okay you're just
not excited
I'm waiting for the brother to hop on
um I guess we'll just finish the
reaction and because there's not too
much left maybe I'll skip to the end or
we could just jump at a random place and
finish it off improved himself as God
everybody and I mean all alive this is a
good part I actually want I want to
discuss this specifically test which of
you are best indeed
Islam develops your character it teaches
you how to carry yourself and how to be
but for what what I asked this last
video why do we need to this test like
is there a war we need to fight in
heaven or something like are we going to
what is he trying to raise an army of
soldiers and the best soldiers like why
do we need to have all these Good Deeds
because I said this before and I'll say
it again if Allah came down here and
proved himself as God everybody and I
mean all eight billion people would be
Muslim there would not be one person who
would say fake and just die they're what
everybody would be Muslim so I'm just
saying it just doesn't make any sense to
me unless there's a reason why he needs
everybody to be completely good I just
don't get it there is a reason we just
don't know exactly but that's what I'm
saying like there's no way that he's
testing us to go to heaven just because
that sounds silly to me but
all right so first and foremost
why are we being tested
he created death and life to test which
of us are best in Deeds which of us are
best in Deeds now you could ask
questions like oh why did God create us
why did and you can ask a question
eventually where it's like as humans we
can't exactly answer that you could say
that Allah created us God created us out
of mercy and so on and so forth but
there's no way to you know really
definitively say answer certain
questions when it comes to the intention
of God the will of God that's just
something we can't fully know but Allah
tests us because imagine you God could
have just spawned Us in on the day of
judgment without having this life and
put some people in heaven and some
people in hell but then the people in
hell will be like I didn't do anything I
didn't live any life and I'm being
punished for for what reason so if you
think about it Allah is letting us go
through this life
to see and also to show us which one of
us is best indeed am I good indeed
because now if you wake up on the day of
judgment with a a load of bad Deeds you
know where you're going you know exactly
why you're going there
right so it's very beautiful and if
Allah were to reveal himself to us and
show us himself even though it's not
possible in this life because Allah
didn't create us for that but if he did
where's the test what is the test there
is no test Allah he gives us enough for
us to see this is the truth as you've
seen in the videos okay let me accept it
and by the way last known you would
actually still have people
that disbelief in God now I'm gonna say
the same time okay I'll let you take it
away then I don't know go ahead go ahead
finish your point go I was just gonna
say and brother Ernest is here so
inshallah well I'm gonna take this video
down and this is the last thing we're
going to say on it before we bring the
brother up for his shahada but even if
Allah did reveal himself to people there
would still be people that disbelieve
how so how can how can they disbelieve
in God when he's right there I don't
mean that they say I don't believe God
you will have the people that say oh our
our eyes have been Bewitched it's a
trick it's a program it's a it's a
hallucinations whatever they'll say
whatever and you'll have those people
but most people will disbelieve how
by disobeying God like Satan himself
like shaytan like the Devil Himself will
speak with God
will basically be up with the angels for
so long
but as soon as God commands him to do
something he says no I'm not going to do
it at that moment he disbelieved in
Allah because he disobeyed him because
we tie worship with obedience directly
so I hope that clears up in this case
ignorance is not Bliss if you are
ignorant you will be punished for it
because
um even if the word of Islam never
reached you even if the word of Allah
the word of God never reached you never
know about God you never know anything
about this stuff right
you're still gonna be judged at the end
how are you gonna be judged that's
absolutely now
if I remember correctly correct me for
my mommy I think you know this one my
memory uh there's a Hadith who is
narrated by the prophet Muhammad he says
that the um
the person was never read received the
message when they passed they're going
to be tested and Allah is going to tell
them like he's going to show them Jannah
he's going to show him jahannam and he's
going to tell them to jump into the
fight and if they jump into the fire
then they go to Jannah because they
obeyed Allah right they obeyed the
Creator but if they jump into Jannah
thinking that ah like that's the most
beautiful thing I'm gonna go here you
said to jump in I'm not jumping over
here bro I'm jumping over here they're
going straight to hell yeah you know
like whether that's how it's going to be
or not Allah Knows Best and like you
were saying you know like what's what's
the exact reason why we are being tested
listen
we have limited intellect for a reason
if we had unlimited intellect
perhaps we would know that but if we had
unlimited intellect then we would be
a stuffed solar like at the same level
as our creator our creator is only one
with this knowledge
right if we had unlimited intellect we
would understand when the day of
judgment is or when we would die we
would understand every little thing
about this existence and that's that's
not it's not possible because we are
limited by Nature you know and
right there's one point where Allah
created the human being a lot of created
Adam
and he was saying that he was going to
send Adam down to earth as the ruler in
that Dominion
and then the Angels asked out of
curiosity not out of arrogance but out
of curiosity I said
would you send someone down there that's
going to cause uh chaos and you know
like Bloodshed and all this stuff
corruption
and all the law said is I know what you
don't
and that's the same with us
like we want to know exactly what we're
being tested listen Allah knows this
it's not up it's not up to us to know if
we knew we probably wouldn't even need
to go through the test
there'd be no point to the test
yeah 100 100 very beautifully said
and on the last note four brothers
Vlad and Eugen one slave of the creator
with the Super Chat says please advise
Vlad and Jurgen to refrain from mockery
and drawing images of Allah they refer
to Allah as a dude in the reaction about
saying Allah and Jannah may Allah guide
them may Allah reward you Allah
to the brothers inshallah because I know
like in in you know the west and in our
societies it's not a big deal joke about
these things but islamically you know
mocking like the prophet saws or Allah
is like one of the worst sins and
depending on what you say you might
actually you know Muslim might be taken
out of the fall of Islam if they say
something like that and there's verses
and actually talk about mocking the
religion and so on and so forth so
but dealing with Muslims obviously is
the best to refrain from that because
they see it as insulting so with that
being said inshallah we're going to
bring up our brother our nest
to take his shahada and sha Allah
Ernest my brother how you doing I'm here
man how you guys doing you hear me we're
doing good we're doing good uh should I
wait for you to turn on your camera are
you gonna do it just audio uh probably
probably just audio just because uh I'm
I'm not in a good necessarily good area
there's like I just got off work and I'm
still kind of at work I'm just kind of
taking my break right now so
hi baby that's taking his break to take
his shahada Allah
ain't nothing more important yes sir bro
all right so I'm going to pull up a uh
little
screen share here can you guys see that
yeah I can see it yes all right perfect
I tied this one up myself because I
think it's a little easier to follow
than the the website so you're just
gonna repeat after me actually before we
do that I have to ask you some questions
so first I'm just gonna ask you a few
questions about what you believe just to
make sure they're in line with what
Muslims believe okay all right I promise
you it's nothing difficult it's very
basic so first and foremost do you
believe that there is only one God
worthy of worship and he has no Partners
no Associates no father no Mom no Sons
no daughters
there is only one God
perfect there's only ever been one God
alhamdulillah beautiful and do you
believe in the angels
do I believe in the Angels yeah like the
angels that Allah describes in the Quran
oh of course
beautiful and do you believe in the
prophets and The Messengers that God
sent peace be upon them I do beautiful
and do you believe in the Revelation the
revelations that God sent with these
prophets like the original Torah the
original gospel the Quran and so on and
so forth I do
beautiful and do you believe in Divine
decree from Allah
I do
and do you believe in the day of
judgment I do believe in the day of
judgment beautiful all right my man and
with that being said inshallah just
repeat after me in Arabic and then we're
going to say it in English
Ash hadu and Allah
[Music]
Allah
[Music]
Anna Anna
muhammadan muhammadan
rasulu rasulo
now you're going to repeat after me in
English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
that there is none worthy of worship
except for Allah except for Allah and I
bear witness and I bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the prophet
Muhammad is the servant is the servant
and messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah
foreign
so how do you feel my man you seem very
knowledgeable on Islam already I do I
can't tell you how much research I've
been doing just for the past year
um on Islam uh I'm you know and that I
came in when I came into the chat uh
last time you guys did the live stream I
was there I still had some questions uh
one of somebody from that chat actually
reached out to me on Twitter
um and he's actually answered he's been
great he's answered a lot of questions
that I had
um I still have a few questions but
um you know I just I'm just trying to
take it how I you know take it as it
goes take it easy I'm trying to learn
everything I can as much as I can you
know because so I can I wanna I wanna
please Allah as much as I can yeah
Allah bless the brother that helped you
out on Twitter and answering the
questions if you have any
if you have any questions for us now you
know feel free to ask I do
um as far as you know because I got
there was a guy I don't know if you guys
remember
um there you guys did a live stream with
young Don you know what I'm talking
about yes we do how do we forget bro
yeah there was a there was a brother on
there a Muslim brother on there that you
guys had I don't I cannot remember his
name at all
um but he has a website and he actually
uh I guess he sends free qurans and I
got the Quran from him
um and I I you know
um and you know through my research you
know of doing Islam I I I've heard that
there's different translations you know
as far as each Quran goes so I'm just
trying to see is there a better Quran
that I should be reading rather than the
one that he sent he sent me which one
did he send you
um it's called the I don't have it it's
in it's in in my uh in my story it's
called The Noble the translation of the
noble Quran
yeah so is it like um is it old old
English like Yi and thou and all that
stuff or is it modern I think it's
modern I'm pretty sure it's modern you
know
yeah as long as it's modern and you can
understand what it's saying you should
be good obviously there are going to be
some words that you just cannot
Translate into Arabic so if you're
curious about adverse you know feel free
to ask you know uh or anybody else will
break it down for you but you'll be fine
inshallah and bro even if it was Old
English you'd be fun like as long as you
took your time like the message will
still get through the first Quran that I
read was an Old English man
and so so and as far as I guess you know
praying goes do I do I need to get a a
specific rug from somewhere or how how
do I necessarily go about doing that
right if you want a rug we'll send you a
rug but you don't need a specific rug
man yeah yeah okay I I didn't yeah I'm
sorry I'm not you know I hope that
wasn't like an offensive question
I'm trying to do it to the best of my
abilities the best that I can
um
um you can pray anywhere as long as it's
clean you can put a towel down you can
pray on the floor if it's clean you're
good inshallah and you're don't worry
you're definitely not offensive my
brother we're very very happy to have
you with us I appreciate you um and one
thing uh on you I I just want to say uh
thank you because
out of everyone here you know no offense
to anyone but everyone here I feel like
I connect with you more because you are
a Reverb correct
um but you know not not to say that I
necessarily I've necessarily never
claimed to be you know I grew up in a
Christian household so to speak I know
but you know I was it was never forced
upon me nor did I ever necessarily you
know claimed to be Christian or anything
like that but just just me hearing all
the live streams and hearing you talk I
just feel like I connect so much with
you
um and I and I appreciate everything and
everything you've ever said because it
really just it it's really you that's
really drawn me towards Islam like just
hearing just hearing everything you've
been through and stuff like that it
really has helped me and I appreciate
you bro I appreciate you man may Allah
bless you because
some people think that I speak too slow
and I bring no value at all so dude
they just you know people that just want
to stir the pot you know it's it's yeah
I'm I'm grateful I'm grateful to hear
that man I'm I'm uh very happy to see
you as a Muslim now oh I'm happy to be
Muslim now um and then last question if
you know I don't know if you guys have
any kind of contact that I can have
maybe on hand just in case I have do you
have any more questions obviously I
can't ask anything right now because
break's about to be up and I gotta get
back but I will but I'm more than likely
we'll have some more questions you know
as I continue my journey and continue
learning if I could have a some sort of
way to reach you guys whether it be
Twitter or an email
yeah so you could do email or I mean if
you have Instagram as well you get the
Amazon uh PM Plus on Instagram
but either way man I mean we can get you
a direct information and we can go from
there inshallah and
um also in the future
um two little notes we are working on
the three Muslims website we're
developing it if you go to it now it'll
be the same thing that it's been for
like the last year but we are we're
working on it so Allah it's going to be
very very nice and inshallah we're going
to include a section four reverse people
just come to Islam people are curious
about Islam and all that stuff and very
special content on there yeah
when did we say this man I um I I
reached out to some actually I asked
some people reach out to me to help out
and alhamdulillah we have an amazing
team working on it uh web web developers
and web designers are amazing
um
I can help too I'm actually in school
for cyber security so you know I know
really yeah
definitely be willing to help out
I'm here man I'm here for you guys and I
appreciate it
is on uh I'm sorry to cut you off no
you're fine but on my Instagram I
actually did a live and there's his
brother on the that I had um he came
onto the stream and he's studying the
same thing and he was saying like how
important this is to be able to protect
yourself online oh yeah at some point we
wanted to bring him on but that would be
dope if we brought both of you on so
y'all could share this beneficial
knowledge to people because it's things
that I actually never really thought
about too in-depth you know you hear
like oh change your password oh like be
be a little bit more secure in what you
do here and there like don't use this
for your password or something but
I guess it's a lot more deeper than what
we think you you would be surprised
there's a there's it it is as you know
the internet technology is going man
it's it's going to be a necessity and
it's very a necessity to be secure if
you're going to be online if you're
going to be using a phone because I mean
there's there's there's an attack you
know a Cyber attack every single minute
you know that I mean just just in the
you know the world alone is over over a
billion dollars lost in just cyber tags
and everything else I mean just recently
where I am they took out a power grid
you know and we we were out we were
there without power for for days so it's
it's uh it's definitely a growing a
growing problem and you know I would and
I would love to you know help every
that's that's pretty much what I plan to
do once I finish just to help everybody
that I can be secure because there's so
many people that are just freely online
without you know knowing how to be
secure you know especially especially
for my Muslim brothers because we're
always under attack it seems like
every time I look up man it's just
something I I you know it's it's it's
crazy
brother Aquila said cyber G had loading
hello that's beautiful okay bro um
that would be amazing
oh yeah man like I would love to I would
appreciate you guys man I appreciate
everything you're doing thank you for
having me here today man thank you for
doing the shahada with me and everything
honestly it's our pleasure like I know
you might be grateful but honestly I
think we should be the Grateful ones
because Allah has blessed us with this
opportunity so honestly I'm I'm very
very honored that you decided to join us
and take your shahada with us out of All
Peoples may Allah thank you appreciate
you guys of course cheers
get in touch with us inshallah
sorry I mean but I'm gonna I'm gonna
send you guys a because I don't have
Instagram I don't I don't do Instagram
that is that street bro
I'm gonna hit you guys on Twitter if you
want to send me an email or send me an
email or if you just want to do Twitter
that's fine but yeah I only I only have
Twitter I don't do Facebook Instagram
all that you know Twitter's not too
secure but those are definitely just for
security they're terrible terrible man
are you making me reconsider having an
Instagram bro you know
you know see you know to to help you
guys out just to see if your email has
ever been compromised phone numbers
anything you guys have you can there's a
way to look all that up to see if it's
ever been compromised if ever people
ever sold your information anything like
that so like I said I'll get at you guys
on Twitter and we can we can go from
there it's good
oh Baby Bro go go to work man we don't
want you to be leaving
of course
we'll talk soon
what a beautiful brother may Allah bless
him I mean bro I mean um one more
announcement we're also inshallah very
soon learning launching a uh the three
Muslims Discord I know everyone's been
asking forever so alhamdulillah we got
Brothers to work on that as well so
inshallah the three muslims.com will be
updated soon and the Discord will be
updated soon so inshallah will have a
place to send our River brothers and
sisters so when they start practicing it
won't just be us it'll be the whole
Community inshallah backing them there
for them insha Allah
honestly I wanted I wanted the teams to
finish everything and then I wanted to
show you guys but uh oh like a surprise
yeah but um that's cute bro enough has
happened that made that made me think
like maybe you guys would want to give
your input while we're creating it so
I'm like yeah
that's nice man yeah I wish I would have
had that when I first started this land
really yeah
and now I mean now we got to do it for
others you know what I mean yeah yeah
that's beautiful right now
everybody I think inshallah we're gonna
go ahead and end this stream off here I
still did not get a DM from vladder
yugen as far as I know so um maybe the
brother my bad the brother that said the
whole thing about the diabetes
please reach out to us because if it's
type 2 bro like I definitely want to
talk with you inshallah
inshallah and um
found the verse from he meant they
recompense of an ill deed is an ill the
like thereof but who whosoever forgives
and seeks to reform his wage is the
affair of Allah he loves not the wrong
doers that's the verse I was talking
about before
bless you and with that being said
for attending everybody take a second
like this dream right now I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you some time inshallah I'm
gonna give you guys some time for the
timer put a Time on there bro
five minutes inshallah another five
minute timer
um
all right inshallah I'm assuming
everybody in the Stream like to stream
right now because they don't know yeah
if you're missing fired if
#so so far you can see this
shot like it up
and with that being said
Allah